en tunisie 88 députés ont signé une
pétition pour la reprise de l'activité
de lance de l'assemblée des
représentants du peuple elle est en
effet a gelé depuis le coup de force du
président aissa yens le 25 juillet
anticonstitutionnelle selon cette
décision figurant parmi les mesures
exceptionnelles mises en place par le
chef de l'état suscitent la colère des
parlementaires qui ont appelé à se
rendre aujourd'hui au parlement on en
parle avec un autre correspondant à une
espèce chips
c'est une pétition qui a trouvé écho
auprès d'une large partie de la classe
politique tunisienne près de 90
parlementaires tous bords confondus ont
répondu à l'appel de trois députés
indépendants pour exiger la reprise de
l'activité de l'assemblée ce vendredi
1er octobre date de la fin des vacances
parlementaires le 25 juillet dernier
après son coup de force le président
sayyed a décidé de limoger le chef du
gouvernement gelée l'assemblée des
représentants du peuple et lever
l'immunité des députés après plus de
deux mois de plus en plus de voix
s'élèvent contre ces mesures
exceptionnelles qui constituent des
atteintes selon ces parlementaires aux
libertés et à la constitution dont le
président de la république a abrogé une
partie écoutez nous pensons que ces
mesures sont contre la légitimité
constitutionnelle et le processus
démocratique
c'est une atteinte aux libertés aux lois
en vigueur et un suicide politique
menaçant l'état et l'unité du peuple
nous déclarons notre résistance ferme à
travers toutes les formes démocratiques
à ces mesures exceptionnelles qui
représente une menace pour la république
et les acquis de la démocratie
plusieurs députés avaient appelé hier à
un rassemblement devant l'assemblée des
représentants du peuple pour contraindre
le président de la république à rouvrir
les portes du palais et de bardot mais
depuis ce matin un important cordon de
sécurité quadrillent les abords du
parlement sur ordre de carthage pour
éviter toute intrusion dans l'enceinte
du bâtiment à la surprise générale à
l'exception de deux députés du parti
ennahdha aucun député n'a fait le
déplacement pas même ce à l'initiative
de ce rassemblement
laissant le champ libre aux journalistes
et aux forces de l'ordre seul
participant à s'être partagé la place du
bardo pour le moment aucune information
n'a été communiquée quant à ce rendez
vous manqué les élus attendent du
locataire du palais de carthage qui
restent or l'application de la
constitution et rétablisse le dialogue
avec les acteurs politiques et sociaux
du pays le communiqué associé à la
pétition précise qu'une réunion des
membres de l'assemblée devrait se tenir
prochainement en vue de discuter de la
tenue d'élections législatives
anticipées